he is baseball hall-of-famer 14 time
all-star
Johnny Bench how many Tigers I'm doing
great
remember the pitch he hit out high
fastball I just figured he was gonna try
to overpower it it went in the upper
deck and it went into the tunnel
actually went through the exit and it
was long as Homer and probably I ever
hit and probably the longest home run
they ever saw yeah in Tiger Stadium
until until I call that slider down and
in from doc Ellis to Reggie and he
almost took the light standard out yeah
no he went he went he went Roy Hobbs he
went natural on 3333 Hall of Famers in
that game three yeah I mean you saw
Stargell I walked in here it is right
here
yeah we're supposed to cue it up yeah no
yeah that's that's Reggie Reggie took
one right out and so you you are 33 33
all the favors and they gave me I mean
that you know start so Mays McDuffie
eridan kala you can go down the list but
it was just under Roberts is there
really my first at-bat I you know this
is after the 70 World Series after
Brooks had stolen everything or maybe
was suddenly good and stolen everything
in the first ball I hit a line shot he
backhands I mean and I'm just running up
and down the line why now again do you
still dream of this stuff County that
you're playing I mean when you go to
sleep at night you wake up so you don't
sleep at all it's what your snow they're
good they're really good but I I'm a
used you know I I did it you know I
played it I did it and everything else
and you know you watched the home runs
now last night I watched the Derby it
was fabulous and I enjoyed every part of
it I enjoy what these kids are doing
today I you know I've heard part of the
first part of it as how do we make boys
baseball fun again and what's wrong with
baseball I don't see anything wrong with
baseball I think it's you know when we
played there were 45 seconds between
commercials so you ran out got ready and
threw your pitches and played them so
but if you take now 2 minutes and 20
seconds which now it was for a while and
they're trying to cut that back you had
an hour and 15 minutes that's three at
three minutes almost per inning to nine
innings you've got 27 minutes extra just
for commercial time so you wind up now
with the game it's 2 hours and 40
minutes
now runs into 310 and I don't still
don't know what people have to do that
why they have to rush home or anything
else I mean what's so important that you
can't sit there and watch The Closer
come in and why can't you see a rally
coming and doing some and enjoy the
intricacies of it now do the guys step
out fix their gloves and scratch their
jocks and do all the stuff too much yeah
they are but you know they they've been
trained now psychologically by their
sports therapist that they need to
really redirect and reach the focus and
so they get out there now they're
thinking about all the hitting things
and everything else and they're going
back to the videos of what they've what
they debt guy did to him last time it's
- I know okay let's see - and oh three
weeks ago he threw me this I mean they
think of that I that's that's the thing
that bothered me most is just guys
stepping out would you have been a even
a better baseball player if that
technology was available to you know do
you think no I knew what was coming
or guessed I like to guess I like to
look you know I tell tell guys even
today I said what do you look for on the
first pitch and some teams say we take
the first strike because we know we like
to get deep in the count we want to work
the pitcher right well I'm saying okay
but if the first pitch is your pitch
those are the major leagues you may see
one pitch every at-bat if you're lucky
and so why wouldn't you set on that
pitch whether it be a hanging curveball
cuz I look curve ball and hit fastball
because I knew I could adjust that
quickly and so I I said here's the pitch
and if it was bad I took it and then I
rezone dim and I it worked out great
well you see all the binders like that a
lot of these managers have and they're
making notes and they're they're taking
stuff out of their pocket and writing
stuff down and and that there's all of
these analytics about that that that
create what we've seen this year a
couple times like the Tampa Bay Rays
starting they're closer a couple of
times because they figure it's
beneficial with the top of the order and
then bringing somebody with all that
information
what would a Sparky Anderson have been
like with that information if it was
ever presented in front of Sparky in the
middle of the seventies Johnny well
Sparky you know somebody said how do you
judge Talent Sparky hmm and he went yeah
pointy to his I pointed to his eye and
he said this is the way I
can see Talent but Sparky used to call
Pete Joe Tony myself in as a group or
individually and they would say what
about if we trade for this guy and we
would say no well what about this guy
yes because we knew kind of like what
his talent ability was he would call you
guys and I guess some of the bigger
names of a big Red Machine yeah to ask
you your thoughts on what a front the
front office might well we were other
Scouts than anybody I mean you don't
need you got a guy up there but stop
watch we didn't have to have a stopwatch
we knew this guy had ball movement in
his own or he was able to fit into a
situation like it's just important to
have a second place hitter as an eighth
place hitter it's just as important have
Terry Crowley and merv rettenmund on the
bench and bill Plummer coming off to
catch and Doug Flynn these are guys that
had to fill in and were they ready when
they were called upon so their role was
just as important and we had to find out
who these people are
Johnny Bench here in the Rich Eisen show
and we'll talk about the Johnny Bench
scholarship fund in a few minutes here
so the homerun Derby
did you ever take part in anything like
that any every day on batting practice
you know Ubuntu yes get it you know hit
me hit and run yes get him over and then
see how far you could hit it I mean it
was like Chicago we we tried to break
out the windows we would break out the
windows across the street so I mean they
talked about these guys how far they hit
it I mean we was we knocked out windows
across the street and people would there
were other teams would actually come out
and watch us take batting practice
because this wasn't anything about you
know keep insides and keep your hands
inside the ball do this stuff and I
don't know if you know that in a 90 mile
an hour fastball you have 0.42 seconds
from the time it leaves the pitchers
hand till it crosses one plate you have
a point one seven second reacts react to
it and how do you make the decision
where the cameras send the signal the
brain sees it it's got to send the nit
to the nerve to the nerves and muscles
and you react so when you start saying
I've got to know I better stay inside
the ball and then you go to the bench
and the guy said you should have hit
that the other way well next time up
there you're thinking this is about the
hitting wall and seeing the ball and
hitting as hard as you can and in
situations you know what you have to do
we had guys that you know could flat hit
and they didn't go up there and say
let's get deep in the count it wasn't
trying to get this picture you throw
deep we didn't care we wanted to get
this guy as many runs as we could in the
first few innings and then work from
there was there such a thing as pitch
count when you play a doll no no right I
mean Jim Maloney are one of the great
right-handers if you ever look it up one
of the great right-handers in the
history of baseball right
he threw a 10 ending no-hitter he walked
10 he hit one he threw 187 pitches and
then he pitched his rotation on the
fourth day how was he
great there's no problem great I mean
but I mean and but we're supposed to get
bigger stronger faster as a human race
we see it I certainly see it in the NFL
oh no it's a why what what can arms no
longer a handle that I think I think
ownership changes and medicine house ala
do you mean because you go in and said I
got a twinge what we better take an MRI
well you have just a slight little fiber
off there well I mean in those days we
used to take capsule and Abilene cream
and rub it and get the hot stuff until
you couldn't stand it and you went out
and you pitched yeah it was it was it
was just you knew you had to play you
know otherwise you would have wound up
without a job and so I saw you were
nodding your head a couple of times when
I was and I'm not just saying that cuz I
want Johnny Bench to st. to the mic but
you were saying the right thing about
what I was saying at the top of the show
here is that I want to see more of the
stars of the game out there right I mean
Bryce Harper and my mind should be his
face should be everywhere today
in front of a microphone talking about
last night yeah he won me over a lot
last night what do you mean by that well
I've never you know I've seen all the
coverage of them and sometimes we social
media and now the media itself can is
focused on that it's like the managers
now you see well they don't have any
reaction because you've got one camera
totally focused on them so if they make
a move excuse me make a move or do
something wrong it's usually shown that
night because we're gonna be showing it
and replaying it and replaying it he was
upset at this guy and how his reaction
was so guys basically aren't going to
expose themselves we see it in golf
golfers now have no emotion but if they
know that they are
they you know we're going to show it you
know he's upset with it so they've been
there protecting themselves plus they
got so much money they don't need a PR
campaign you know they're making
hundreds of million dollars I made 2.2
in my entire career
your entire playing career yeah so I
started off at 11,000 is that why you
were doing stuff like the base what was
promoting myself is that well yeah but I
wasn't afraid you know I had like the
baseball Bunch games people play right I
had you know golf in paradise but it was
the way I had to me I made more money in
the offseason than I did playing just
because you know and I'm trying to but
people wanted me and I wasn't afraid to
do it so I was promoting myself now
these guys if you've got you know you're
making 2 million dollars a week every
other week now they can they don't
really have to go out and promote or
anything else they can stay right there
and protect themselves and people are
you know people are after you a lot you
know you go out have a drink at a at a
restaurant some Red Sox fan doesn't like
a ganky fan and he from any tweets or
calls and said Johnny Bench is driving
drunk I mean so you you face that these
days and so these guys are really
protecting themselves they've got you
know they got their posses they got
their agent you know they got somebody
saying you need to do this and somebody
saying you need to be there and so they
become isolated in so many ways that's a
bummer well bit of a bummer I mean I'm
you know I cuz I'd love to get to know
again but but that's me I understand I'm
not living the life that you've just
described you know you found out about
it though true recognition things that
you do well I guess so no no okay but
what I mean is I guess I'm still out
there I know that that's maybe why
that's what helps put a roof over my
head but and and I understand that a
show that I do right here like I'd love
to just be sitting next to Bryce Harper
in our number-3 talking about last night
you know but so I understand that I I do
have my own agenda and I have this I
said there's been a lot of part of you
as a player you know you want
Bryce on the show Dan wants his race
sure you want this and then the local
guys wants to do it and then you I mean
you look down on the crowd last night
and I'm
Media people were there tons and they
all want something and you can't always
share it so sooner or later you
basically just said like can't do
anything or I won't do anything well I
want to take a break be back in 60
seconds stole down a little bit more of
all-star memory lane and then get into
this poll question a little bit more
about who you'd want to build a team
around oh gosh we could talk about those
things just that's the great thing about
baseball
you know the guys sit around and always
kibbutz about who does this and who's
the trade and who's gonna make a better
better player so you know when he when
he talks about judge yeah I mean he's a
guy that's a personality he plays with
personality we'll talk about it after we
come back from break you want to throw
260 say you want to do this back we'll
be back in sixty minutes here on the
rich I've second second away second 60
seconds no I want to talk a minute okay
right come back grab something back on
the Rich Eisen baseball Bunch
Johnny Bench here for another segment on
the Rich Eisen show okay ask the poll
question of Johnny Bench Cris Brockman
go find mr. Benge who would you build
your franchise around mookie betts Bryce
Harper Aaron judge Manny Machado Mike
Trout Mike Joe
you didn't stutter no no and Machado
but if you had to choose one it would be
trout that l'autre what do you love
about him I just love his the whole
thing he's a kid playing baseball you
know everything about him is running
around the bases going into the dugout
and putting his head down he hits home
run he puts his head down he runs around
the bases doesn't try to show up anybody
he plays the outfield as hard as he can
play it he jumps over over the but he's
just he's an inspiration to kids he's
like this is fun I still love playing
the game and Machado is so talented
judge is a guy that I really enjoy yeah
he strikes out too much but you know
he's still close to 300 and he hits the
long ball he can do it he's in the
clutch situations do we got else bets
bets yeah amazing what he's doing in 367
or something made close to that no you
know the real guy up there is
JD Martinez what he liked about his dud
man stud you put it on the line he'll do
it I mean look at what he did in Arizona
you know he turned that team around too
because you got to have somebody in the
middle of that lineup that you can rely
on
and those guys really make it easy for
him because a bettin a veterinary button
Rd mm-hm
penny Cindy been attending great little
kid watch him I love to watch him I'm
like bets they set it up for him and
this guy when it comes down to it he
takes a load off the back of the lineup
but he drives in he's got what 80 RBIs
already well I mean you know and then
there's the guy who got the award for
most votes ready I know about Rubio
who've a yeah I could I watch him every
day I don't care
I checked the Bucks course I'm a box
poor guy yeah I will watch out to he's
everything here is another 130 hits
already amazing it's just it what do you
what does morgan think ham do you talk
baseball would jump when you get a
chance you know joe joe and i don't talk
a lot but we love him but Joe you know
Joe's gone through a lot of you know
with the health or Merrill yep and he's
great now he's walking without his cane
he's got it and I you know we talked and
his mother passed away I don't say Joey
you know I talk to talk to you but still
my my sympathies go out and I told you
off the air you know when I first got
tspn I'm a 26 year old kid and loving
baseball that's what I did for ESPE and
more than any other sport and Joe is
great to me he's a clear easy quiz rate
he was raising a lot raising he was
really the change that made the
difference in our bulk him and John
Miller or just maybe the best ball
player I've ever played with her scene
was Joe Morgan yeah why is that
yeah steal the base get a walk Gold
Glove and if it was on the line he'd
drive in the run so there wasn't
anything he couldn't do and he
understood how to do it so you choose
trout to build your team around who is
best catcher in the game today Johnny
well probably Salvador Perez is probably
the best defensive catcher you know
you'll never get the recognition unless
you put the offensive numbers up you
know it's real Mutoh down in Miami
mm-hmm he's like 5th in the voting
he's hitting over 300 45 RBIs what do
you think of Sanchez has it he still
needs to move around to plate a little
bit well everybody says that joy you
know you got a pitching staff like that
they throw me so many different pitches
guys throw 200 pitches a game and you
wind up well he's got 15 pass balls so
what I mean you know these guys cross
you up or they move it or some ball does
something right it's hard he's a big guy
but he can he can hit he got a great arm
and I mean I obviously
I like him a lot and what do you think
of the Buster Posey rule certainly since
we're here in the all-star game and we
all know about your colleague Pete Rose
barreling into Ray Fosse that's still a
moment to this day that everybody keeps
talking about do you like that rule
player safety rule put in place in
baseball well Bruce called me Bochy
called me now Bruce it at 3:00 catchers
carried off the field mm-hmm and it got
to the point where you know some people
don't like it but today's game you got
guys that are six to 220 rounding third
base and they're gonna make SportsCenter
by knocking the catcher in the dugout
well you got all the equipment on yeah
you got a piece of that for your chest
protector and you got everything else
exposed and these guys come flying in
there and you know why now we can't take
out the second baseman in a double play
I mean that's changed but it's proved
that it's it's helped it's such a funky
rule about how to block the plate I
never stood on the line in any way I
always stood out in front of the plate
because I wanted them on the ground if
they see the home plate they'll slide
you don't see too many guys today that
don't slide and that's because they see
home plate but if you're standing in the
line blocking on plate people are gonna
start thinking about knocking you in the
dugout from 90 feet away and they got a
full head of steam so I don't know why
you know we I've got I get hit in midair
I guess I gotta I had a whole Klayton
work on my on my uniform
where guys hit me in the mid air and you
know if they hit me the wrong way I'm
out for the rest of the year right and
then I'm having I've had no surgeries
and by that time I've had no knee
surgery Johnny Bench Evan I was really
smart guy kept my foot pointed at the
runner so he had to go up the shin guard
well I gotta tell you - it's some of the
best running backs in the history in the
National Football League the most yards
and longevity knew how to get hit knew
how to move their body to avoid the hit
also knew that if I went in this hole
based on the defense that I saw before
the snap I'm gonna get my head knocked
off so I'm going to choose this home and
I get down now I'm gonna I mean he it
yeah there's a certain professionalism
in understanding the game
keeps you healthy - well I mean there's
this guys that you know I the quads are
everything for the knees the stronger
the quads better than these they will
support them so if you ever have a knee
problem you want to build up your quads
kids that are gonna catch build up your
quads and you will do it and learn and
you will not have nearly as many knee
injuries and you won't be squatting down
and putting so much pressure on it
because the quads will actually support
it what'd you say - Pete after he blew
up ray Fosse comes well you know thy God
he appeared had ray out to dinner that
night before at his house so they were
good friends if you watch it and close
enough and you've seen it so many times
Pete starts the headfirst slide and when
he started the headfirst slide
here's Fosse shin guard standing right
there and he almost had a little stumble
and then came up because he couldn't
headfirst slide and then it was but it's
a you know the game's on the line the
the game is on the line and you look at
him he's saying are you all right ray
watch him he starts to see how he starts
to mm-hmm and then that's it there he
goes down yeah we Pete I mean that's us
though but the game is on the line so
you've got to do something with it
I got ran into similar to that by Gary
Matthews in 1975 mmm-hmm
I had six cortisone shots every three
weeks to finish the season just because
they tore up the AC joint the cartilage
in between the acromial and the co Vick
Euler and they tore it up and but I had
to finish the season and then I had the
surgery after the season was over but I
mean we're gonna we're gonna get banged
we're gonna get hit and so I like it
actually
I like the way it is the Johnny Betts
the Johnny Bench scholarship fund jb5 F
dot org what's that all about Johnny
yeah yes v is either I got I didn't go
to college I really wanted to go to
college
part of my signing bonus is six thousand
dollars in cash was bonus check and then
one thousand dollars for each semester
because I was going to go to college I
felt like I needed to and then so when I
retired I hadn't been because I went to
winter ball instructional league every
year and then by that time I was
established and I couldn't go back and
so I said we want to give you something
I said what I'd like to start us
scholarship fund so we have I started
with it I had golf tournament I donate
from I had two hundred and fifty
thousand from Who Wants to Be a
Millionaire that we gave to it and we've
got a minimum were usually eighty to
eighty students a year that are on
scholarship from Cincinnati and Binger
Oklahoma and they've had to play sports
they're not going to play sports in
college necessarily but they've had to
play sports and if they're local enough
that they get an education usual stay in
the area they are and the city becomes
better because of their education Johnny
Bench National Baseball Hall of Famer
first ballot ninety six point four two
percent of the vote - do we know who the
three point line drives percent no a lot
of guys wouldn't vote a first first
ballot because they'll like Ruth didn't
make it or whatever and you know at the
end of the year into my career I played
I moved to first and third guys did it
guys now they may have had have been
better I might not have talked to
certain reporters I mean you know as to
how Ted Williams was when he went didn't
when the MVP when he hit four Oh three
or four he did 401 he didn't get the to
New York writers didn't vote for him
that year and he didn't win the MVP
DiMaggio wanted there so you can you can
upset a reporter for whatever reason hmm
and you know it's what it is but I got
in yes you see I got the ring and it's
on your left hand so you know whether
it's a vote or not or whatever I mean
it's such a it's just one of the
greatest honors and in life
well Johnny thank you for coming on your
leisure by the way thanks for the batter
up idea years ago in my backyard you
weren't the one with the aluminum bed
I'm not the one with the aluminum bat
that you say some kid took it out and
then there is a liability issue that
took that I guess that sat down on the
batter up that benched the batter out
can we can we answer the is a poll
question go fill there yeah what do you
where do we got what are the reason what
are the results so for look up Johnny
Bench Chris Brock go ahead ask Chris
Pratt before the results over there
Johnny Bench a Mike Trout leading away
right now 68% you put your thumb on the
scale Mookie out on the bottom Manny
Machado milk 2% and then and everyone
else in the middle ten percent
mookie betts Bryce Harper Aaron Judd
okay there you go one again Machado news
when we come back apparently on the moon
Dodgers I don't know Yankee will have
will find that we'll do our best to find
that out Pudge Rodriguez the
Commissioner of baseball Rob Manfred now
Leiter still to come the Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on audience